as the temperature once again fell below
zero they continued to search the water
for any signs of life
children have been playing on ice on
this Lake in solihull and fell into the
freezing water people nearby did
everything they could to help when our
firefighters arrived a number of police
officers and members of the public were
in the water trying to reach and rescue
the children
our crews entered the water
swam to the first child and our
specialist trained firefighters
including technical rescue rescued three
further children
the four children pulled from the water
were in Cardiac Arrest they were given
CPR and taken to nearby hospitals
many hours after these children were
first reported as having fallen into the
lake more specialist search teams
continue to arrive but due to the
temperature of the water and the length
of time they now don't expect to pull
anyone else out alive
as emergency work goes through the night
local people can only wait for news I
think it's everybody is shocked and
everybody of course is going through a
hard time especially that we don't know
exactly what happened but when we heard
about that there are children involved
in this matter so we decided to come
here personally and pray at the sides
the thoughts of everyone here are with
the families and friends of the children
it is a horrifying reminder of the
danger of these freezing conditions